[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
addie hour you can probably tell from
the background we're doing something a
little bit different again this time as
well so i'm actually grateful to the
yield broadcast studio we're actually
recording in the podcast studio today so
a little bit of a different setting
but again grateful to be here with all
of you today i have the immense pleasure
of welcoming a friend colleague and
mentor dr charles dk and today we're
going to be talking about faith
spirituality and psychiatry so three
topics that we don't often hear in the
same sentence but something i think is
very good very good for us to continue
to think about and to discuss
and as i've already alluded to dr dk has
been a mentor to me in a lot of ways
specifically around these topics but in
other ways as well and so for me it's
really full circle to be able to welcome
him to the podcast in some ways the
reason i'm actually sitting here having
this conversation with all of you is
because of the mentorship that he's
given me over the years so again
grateful that he's taken the time to
invest in me and that he's taking the
time to be here with us in this
conversation
all right thank you doctor
thank you very much dr idea i think
you're being too kind no
thank you
not at all those those early
conversations early in my career
definitely had an impact all right
so i'm also excited that you all get to
get to know dr dk a little bit as well
and to hear some of his insights on this
podcast so i did want to start just by
giving a little bit of an introduction
to him he has lots of different roles
and lots of different titles so i'm only
going to give a few of them here
but dr dk is currently the chief medical
officer in the office of the
commissioner for the connecticut
department of mental health and
addiction services he's also an
associate professor in the department of
psychiatry and co-director of the law
and psychiatry division
he's co-editor of behavioral sciences
and law the behavioral sciences and law
journal and he also chairs the ethics
committee for the american psychiatric
association
he also has a lot of awards and
accolades he's been named as a
distinguished fellow for lots of
different organizations the one that
caught my eye in particular was the fact
that he is a diplomat in clinical
psychiatry to the royal college of
physicians and surgeons of ireland that
one i did not i did not expect to see
maybe i'll have him expand on how that
came about as well but again just
honored and grateful to be able to
welcome charles dk to the addi hour
podcast thank you
and so as you all know and as dr dk
knows as well i usually just like to
start out checking in with our guests to
see how they're doing at this point in
time so dr dk if we could just start by
asking how you're doing these days with
your day-to-day activities and with
everything that you navigate
and try to juggle as it were
family life and professional life as
well
yes
well thank you so much for inviting me
and thank you for the introduction
i am doing well i'm very grateful
very grateful that every day i am
healthy and well my family is healthy
and well
despite the ravages of covid
and the two years of intense
protests across the country and across
the world i'm just grateful that we are
still here and we're doing well and
we're healthy
excellent yeah i think that's so well
said and so important and
grateful that we can be even in this
space in this conversation again as you
mentioned with everything that's gone on
over over the last few years and of
course with things that happened before
that which have also come to light in a
lot of ways
and i know we'll jump into this even
more so in the conversation but i know
that will be part of the topic that
we'll talk about as you've invested in
some of these topics in so many
different ways as well but as listeners
heard you do have a lot of different
leadership roles which i mentioned so i
also wonder if you could just let our
listeners know what your day-to-day or
day-to-days
look like on a regular basis how you
occupy and
and spend your time during the day
yeah i have been
privileged even blessed
to hold all of these positions
uh of authority of leadership
and my my day-to-day is often consumed
by
working for the department of mental
health and addiction services
uh being at the table where decisions
are made regarding the provision of
services
to our patients the fighting for
resources
for
our patients uh psychiatric severely
mentally ill
individuals uh have often been
marginalized in our society so we have
to fight for everything uh to enhance
their care to enhance their well-being
and to protect them uh in in our society
so my day-to-day job is often
fighting those battles at the
areas where i am able to make policy
decisions
and and uh
and and ideas and things that relate to
that
i also have been privileged to
participate in the education and
training of the
next generation of physicians and
psychiatrists and forensic psychiatrists
so my i have the dual
opportunity to both participate in the
provision of care but also train
individuals who will do the same in the
future that's a real blessing i think
very well said and again many of us are
grateful for the work that you are doing
in these roles and for the impact that
you have in the community just to pick
up on one thing that you mentioned that
you said the beginning is that you have
the opportunity the privilege and the
blessing to be at the table and to be
involved in these decision making
processes um i was curious if you could
take our listeners on a little bit of a
journey about how you got to the table
in the first place how did you arrive in
this place because that's something that
isn't always granted to many of us
especially those of us from black and
brown communities so i'm curious if you
could share about that aspect of the
journey as well
yes
i um i i went to medical school in
nigeria
and then after that i had my residency
training in psychiatry in england
which is where i obtained all those
degrees including the the one from
ireland
and then from after that i came to the
us
additional training in chicago
and finally i had my fellowship training
in forensic psychiatry
rtl
after the training i started working at
the
maximum security psychiatric hospital in
connecticut
and i did that job for about four years
and one of the blessings i would say is
that
my time at that position led to dramatic
improvement
in the a lot of individuals who were
really really ill are very difficult to
manage refractory
and as a result of serious mental
illness had committed crimes
which is why they ended up in the
maximum security psychiatric hospital
but
the uh being able to change the tone of
the work on that unit
to
just making life easier and better for
the patients like a dramatic improvement
on that unit and therefore when the
position of the medical director of that
hospital came up
i applied along with other people across
the country
but i was chosen to do the same across
the hospital to improve the services of
patients
across the hospital that's how i became
medical director of that hospital
then i continued the same processes it
led to another significant improvement
uh across the hospital now of course you
know that this type of work is not just
one person it's you and a lot of other
people
but just being able to motivate others
and work with them to get to the point
where
the whole hospital was had also improved
remarkably
and so on then i became the head of that
hospital
then after a while the idea
came from the commissioner's office that
maybe
i should participate in doing the same
across the state
then there was another interview
and by this time my work had become
recognized publicly i had been
interviewed by the boston globe and npr
and people had shown light on the
changes that had happened
at the hospital and i was being
consulted to do the same across the
country but then so when the
commissioner's office um i when i was
lucky enough to be hired to be the
deputy medical director in the
commissioner's office
that was the start of
the enhancement i would say expansion of
my role across the system
that's wonderful to hear that that's
during that trajectory and also to know
that
people were paying attention to the
impact that you were having but then as
you appropriately mentioned it wasn't
just you there were teams of people that
you were working with to make this
impact as well and so i think that's
really important to be able to highlight
i'm also curious as much as you're
willing to share i mean you've talked
about the successes along the way and
not to detour too far from our topic but
i think it's also important for people
just to know about the successes and the
challenges that came along the way as
well so as you are making your way up
and having this impact was there any
pushback um that you noticed at any
point along the way were those were
there any who are trying to detract you
from
what you were trying to do or was it
something that just was a smooth process
uh moving forward
i could write a book about the
challenges and the materials and the
obstacles they were huge
um you know i think change is hard to be
to start with change is extremely hard
to change the culture of a an
institution that has been existing for a
while that has
what i would call practices not policies
but negative practices to change that
culture is pretty hard to change the
culture as a young man coming from yale
who's black i think is even additionally
very hard i had lots and lots of
headwinds
and challenges and detractors
but i think ultimately i i was able to
prevail but i again i want to highlight
the fact that my being able to prevail
had to do with my
that's for my faith i mean i was
determined
and i had to see myself as working for a
higher power
not working for a regular human being
because
you have to have something beyond you
to be able to overcome the challenges
that come in front of you
and i had to hold on tight to the fact
that at the end of the day i could go
home and say have i pleased my god today
despite all what people have done today
have i done that
and so being able to have a your own
faith in your own
uh
i would say connections that tightness
that allows you to move forward
regardless of challenges
are things that i have personally
benefited immensely from and continue to
guide me today
yeah
that's wonderful to hear and the
fortitude and the undergirding that it
sounds like your faith was given you
in that journey along the way as well i
know we're going to tie it back to that
throughout this conversation but one
thing i also want to ask would you say
are there ways in which your faith and
what you have been doing your vocation
would you say that represented a calling
and if so how how has that been a
calling how have you carried that out
i think that the biggest area that i
always highlight in my own head is
that to whom much is given
much is expected
um i also have i i would call it a
spiritual religious faith injunction to
take care of the less fortunate
the biggest driving force for me that
kept me going regardless of all
obstacles was because i focused my
attention on the less fortunate and
trying to improve the lot of the less
fortunate therefore no matter how
difficult things looked like to me no
matter how challenging they look like to
me they were nothing compared to what
some of our patients were dealing with
so the the injunction to pay attention
to the less fortunate became a really
driving
and a faith injunction for me as well as
the idea that i always appreciate that
that much has been given to me
and i'll have to use this much to make
an a a a difference and be able to stand
at the end of the day every day stand
and say have i made a difference today
well that's i mean that's very
encouraging to hear and also in a sense
humbling as well because i think many
people could look at you with all the
accolades that you've gotten and put you
up on a pedestal whereas it seems like
you're trying to do the reverse and
really think about
those who you are serving and what they
are walking through and just being
humble in that approach so i think
that's very very refreshing to hear a
lot of ways and i think speaks to um the
benefit that we have as a society of
having people and individuals like you
who are truly invested in the work and
seeking to make an impact in people's
lives so i you know on behalf of lester
i just want to thank you for
that approach and that investment as
well and and obviously
not only for those who you're serving in
those specific roles but as you've
mentioned as you're training others as
well and serving in many different ways
thank you
so you also touched on the fact that
change is hard and that's something that
has been an important conversation in
the last few years but even with the
topics that we're talking about today
thinking about
faith and
spiritual practice spirituality and
psychiatry how has that tied in with how
all those three tied in together because
i would imagine that there are aspects
of resistance there there are aspects of
openness so what has been your
experience as a person of faith trying
to be invest in people's lives as a
psychiatrist where do you see some of
the tension points and where do you see
some of the opportunities
really
great but complicated
question
you know when you look back in history
far far far before the
development of medications
and
development of mental and even medical
specialties that we have today
spirituality was paramount was at the
center of everything people would you
know illnesses were explained
by
by one's spiritual beliefs or
spirituality
um the healing was from spiritual
beliefs and spirituality religion faith
such that people would say that
something was wrong with your spirit now
we need to fix your spirit somehow to
get you better this we could really go
back to before medicine and then with
science and with technology and with all
these new things happening
spirituality
faith began to take a background began
to really be moved aside
and as far as psychiatry is concerned i
think one of the biggest challenges
that then happened was when one of our
i would say the father of psychotherapy
one of the main figures in psychotherapy
sigmund freud
stated that the belief in god was
actually a reason why people got sick
sometimes that anxiety neurosis might
all be due to the fact that people
believed in god
and therefore the way to heal human
beings
was to use psychotherapy
to
disconnect them from the belief in in
god and that might help them get better
uh and you so a lot of people because he
had a huge voice a loud voice a big
voice that became a very very serious
problem in psychiatry
i have to say though that his voice was
not the only one there there were
counter voices
but they were not quite as loud as
sigmund freud i mean carl jung's belief
was the reverse
he said that mental illness was because
people were deviating from god deviating
from the practice of god
so the struggle i'm just saying the
struggle between
where does you know faith spirituality
and so on fall in psychiatric care has
been existing for a long time
but what then happened was that the
biological psychological and social
aspects of care
uh took um center stage and religion and
spirituality were pushed aside and that
has been the case for a while
and you know to compound on this i think
that
the
there was a disconnect there's always
been this disconnect where
the vast majority of adults in america
believe in god and they believe
in spiritual religious practices the
vast majority
use their religious beliefs to cope with
stress
and distress
and other things that happen with mental
disorders
so the vast majority of people do that
in the u.s
even those who do not believe in the god
of the bible so to say believe in a
supernatural being or a supernatural
power or force which they also connect
with
uh to help them resolve difficulties so
on the one hand you have a public that
is chipped in religion and religious
beliefs and spirituality and faith
and then you have the treatment
community
that
do not have that they have the reverse
psychiatrists have the least connection
to spirituality they have the least
connection to god the least belief
that there is
that god exists or that there
their problems can be resolved through a
focus on their spirituality uh
psychologists many of them are atheists
or agnostics so the vast majority of
treaters
mental health professionals do not have
those kind of connection to spirituality
whereas the vast majority of the
potential patients
believe in that
and that that has been the struggle so
far i would say um
there's a lot there and i think it's
helpful that you've taken us through the
history as well i wonder and some you
know some listeners may already be
deeply familiar with this as well but
for those who aren't so what type of
because as you're talking
to me that only sounds like tensions
that are just waiting to happen what
types of tensions has that created over
the years in terms of the general
population and the practitioners i mean
has there been room for dialogue and i
know that some things are shifting but
i'm just curious historically how that
actually
has played out in terms of trying to
bring care to people
i'm very happy that things are changing
and i can talk about the change in a
little bit but
how it has played out is that
individuals of faith
who have mental health problems
have had difficulty presenting their
full selves
to their psychiatrist or their therapist
or their psychology social worker
because presenting their full self would
mean presenting elements
of their religious beliefs
and spirituality
and it's not because they haven't even
done that they had done some of it in
the past
but the response they had received from
clinicians have not been helpful
they have been dismissed
even disparaged
or made to feel less than
and and so they haven't been able to
really fully explore their full selves
in treatment
and aspects of treatment that
you know wholeness of care which looks
at the body the spirit the mind
the community all of those things are
involved in patient-centered care you
have to look at all of them
but when a patient feels that they can't
come with all of themselves to you
that would lead to discouragement in
even seeking psychiatric care
and these are the individuals who have
overcome the stigma the already huge
stigma associated with mental illness so
once you fight the battle you'll fight
the stigma you overcome it and then you
see a psychiatrist and then the
psychiatrist belittles your beliefs or
disparages it or makes you feel like you
know you are the problem
i think that really has been problematic
but the good news
the good news is that that's shifting
now
in that the vast majority of
psychiatrists are now open to this
they are willing to listen
they are willing to try trying to
understand where you're coming from
and trying to work with the patients to
support them in this journey
i one of the things that has also helped
this movement
is the fact that there's a the recovery
movement recovery
uh is now a huge term in psychiatry
recovery movement recovery centered care
that really centers on a journey it's an
individual's journey in life it doesn't
focus so much on the symptoms
and the signs and disabilities but in
fact more what gives you meaning what
gives you hope what helps you recover
what helps you overcome stressors and
what's the journey of life for you
so that that's that movement has has
helped enhance
uh the the need to focus on the full
person including their spirituality and
their religion
that's definitely good to hear and it
seems like there's a mutual or a goal at
least of trying to have a mutual
understanding and more of a holistic
approach to allowing people to bring
their full selves to that situation so
they can walk on that journey
in a more
effective and holistic manner which is
definitely encouraging to hear i'm
curious in terms of the shift that you
talked about what are some of the other
aspects that you think have been helpful
in that shift because it sounds like
there has been misunderstanding i mean
we've talked about from the
psychiatrists or psychiatrists or
psychologists but likely both ways as
well also from those from faith
communities coming into these spaces
likely partially due to the disparaging
that they felt beforehand but what are
ways that some of those
misunderstandings have been clarified
would you say
i think um so i'll take the
misunderstandings from both sides from
the clinicians
and then from the patient's point of
view
i think the clinicians
many of them are worried that they are
not really trained
uh
to engage in these discussions
and um
they feel ill equipped to be able to
participate in discussions that have to
do with spirituality and religion
if you
add to the to that the idea that in this
country
religion
faith spirituality is considered
something that is personal
it's a private matter we shouldn't be
talking about it in public
uh what if we have differences of
practices if i have a from a different
faith and you're a different faith how
are we going to engage together
in
therapy how can we talk about these
things
some of people clinicians are also
worried that the way they respond might
be upsetting to patients if they don't
respond appropriately or they make
comments that might not work properly
um and then there are those who are
worried also that a focus on
spirituality and religion could detract
from the work of psychotherapy for them
that's something different
i think people are beginning to
understand that the work of
psychotherapy can be enhanced by these
areas opposed to being detracted by it
but this is what some people have
worried about
others who have focused more on science
have wondered whether this was
since this was not based in science
speaking of faith spirituality religion
is not based in science
and i'm a scientist therefore i really
shouldn't be wasting my time in those
areas that has been one other
misunderstanding
and finally i think some have wondered
if it's even ethical to practice you
know to bring spirituality and religion
in this treatment space that is almost a
sacred psychotherapy or psychiatric
treatment space
so those have been the misunderstandings
from the
mental health clinician's point of view
the misunderstandings from patients
have also been very difficult
um some of them have thought that um
even considering
mental health symptoms or focusing on a
mental health symptom or having mental
health problems is evidence of their
moral failings
but this is fact this is what shows that
they have failed morally that they have
sinned
uh this might be a punishment from from
from god or somebody else for their
sinfulness
and they view the idea of seeking
psychiatric treatment as evidence that
they are failing to trust god because
really all you need to do is confess
you know do all the things you need to
do then pray fast and have others pray
for you and you will be fine and but not
doing that and seeking psychiatric help
is uh
not trusting god it's evidence that they
don't trust god
others um
even avoid beneficial
treatments if they perceive that these
beneficial treatments would conflict
with their religious beliefs
which is a really important
thing to consider because if you think
that this is against your religion
or might conflict with it you might have
difficulties even engaging or listening
or participating in it
others sometimes use their religious
beliefs to
justify
whatever is going on with them you know
if there's abuse in a marital
relationship well you know you really
can't break up
you know it's part of you know this
the spirituality or their faith beliefs
might make them stay
where they are supposed to be
and they're probably not willing to
listen to a therapist who might be
trying to figure out other ways for them
to engage uh with society
so you see the misunderstandings on both
sides on the patient's sides and on the
clinician side
that's where the difficulties happen
yeah and so many pieces of what you've
you've pulled out i think are helpful
for people just to hear and reflect on
as well another thought that came to
mind i mean one of the things that we've
talked about a lot on this podcast has
been the idea of cultural competence and
just knowing people's cultural
backgrounds especially for mental health
professionals
making sure that they understand where
people are coming from what their lived
experiences and not trying to take one
way of life and superimpose it upon
another individual as you're talking it
makes me think that this aspect of faith
and spirituality also falls within that
umbrella of cultural competence having
an understanding of people's faith
background what their how they are
bringing themselves to the table and
able to be able to
navigate and walk through that with them
as well i mean has that been something
that you've seen in your experience
either in your practice or talking with
others as well
it has been um in fact the american
psychiatric association has recognized
this
in our
diagnostic and statistical manual for
mental disorders the so-called dsm
the cultural formulations and cultural
formulation interview has
become really prominent
um psychiatrists are encouraged
to ask questions about people's
religious beliefs
but you know um and as part of that
cultural
uh formulation it's religion
spirituality family moral identity
for some people you can't talk about
their culture without including
religious beliefs moral identity
spirituality is part of their culture
you can't see then that you are
culturally competent when you ignore
this huge element
of their culture therefore
asking questions in these areas about
how these cultural elements such as the
religion spirituality have been helpful
or stressful or supportive to test the
individual in front of you is crucial
because the fact of the matter is that
sometimes they could be quite stressful
to people even as they could be
supportive to people and you need to
understand them so that you can be able
to provide more appropriate care to
people
so yes cultural
uh competence cultural respect more or
less these days is is is crucial
in this discussion
and that's great that it's been
incorporated and that's been
incorporated with all aspects too so not
assuming that it's been beneficial
beneficial or harmful but giving
individuals the opportunity to have that
space to have those conversations
because as you mentioned it can go
both ways
another piece which you mentioned is
just you know this idea of
incompatibility between
faith and psychiatry or psychology and
science and as we've been having the
conversations on this podcast as we've
hosted different town hall events it's
been very interesting to see how people
are starting to talk more about the ways
that those things are compatible i mean
i've had conversations with people who
said they grew up always
being told or having to understand they
were incompatible or starting to see
some of that compatibility more so um
over the years even in terms of you know
some of the spiritual practices and some
of the psychological interventions i
mean so much so that people are thinking
about well how are those spiritual
practices actually impacting people's
brains and how they approach certain
situations and how they navigate through
things i've had you know pastors who've
asked clinical psychologists whether
their practice of reading through um
scriptures is an aspect of cognitive
behavioral therapy and you know just
thinking about all the intersection that
comes with those pieces as well so i
wonder if there's any aspects of
congruency or consistency that you've
also noticed just in your in your
experiences as well
i think that um
one of the really cool
things that i believe
uh are happening now is the
incorporation of spirituality into even
regular care
all right so i'm gonna get to that in a
minute but
if you look at the
treatment formulation for
mental disorders
in the past and which has really held
sway for many years
they've been biological treatment which
is
you know medications
um
investigations
the different types of investigations
and so on so biological treatment
psychological treatment which is the
psychotherapy the opportunity for
individuals to
present their struggles and have a
trained person help them navigate the
struggles and the difficulties and help
them overcome them
you know which can be through all kinds
of methods whether it's through you know
changing or how you think
understanding how how you think affects
how you behave and how you feel and
helping you work through that or any
other forms of therapy
then i think a really important element
of treatment that people brought in was
the social treatment
which is you know
homelessness housing food insecurity
violence if you if you live in if you
have any of these things as part of your
life
it's very hard for you to fully recover
if you're going to go back to an abusive
home you're going to go back to an
environment of violence you're going to
you're not going to have enough money to
support yourself no transportation to
access services
and no food if you don't have any of
those elements and you're you know
unemployed it's very hard for you to be
successfully treated with medicine and
psychotherapy so i think the addition of
this social element has been a real
boost
but what has been missing all this time
is the addition of the spiritual element
because for a lot of people that's just
how they cope they cope
with their spirituality their hope is in
their spiritualities and their wholeness
is in their religion it's in their faith
and therefore no matter how much of all
of these other elements you bring
together if you don't enhance the
ability to participate in these areas
it's going to fall short
and so i have been really fascinated and
impressed with the
newer treatment modalities
that have included
spiritually focused or
modified treatments that have augmented
spirituality into regular care
i have been really fascinated by that
and by the findings that are coming out
from those types of studies
now now i'm curious what are some of
those findings that have that have come
out as people have
have been delving into this area some of
which i'm familiar with but i think
it'll be great uh to have you share on
that and for our listeners as well
i think that the first thing to even
talk about is why is or how is it that
people believe that
religion and spirituality are beneficial
even just alone by itself without the
addition of those things into treatment
just alone
lots of research have come up in recent
years that show that you know people who
participate in religious activities
um have a
just a better health generally physical
and mental health generally people who
um are more religious uh
and they participate regularly in their
religious activities are physically
healthier they have healthier lifestyles
they require fewer health services
that's just broadly speaking but then um
women research that have looked at women
who attended weekly religious services
found that they had lower mortality
compared to those who did not and the
more frequent they attended the
religious services the lower the
mortality rate which is really
interesting
uh attendance at religious services
people found were associated with
decreasing depression
and a six-fold reduction in suicide risk
wow so just the subjecting of these
ideas into research is showing these
benefits
that high intrinsic religiosity
often leads to more rapid remission of
depression to those individuals who have
depression and people also who have this
high interesting religiosity
um they adapt more successfully to
stress and more quickly than those who
do not have it
so that's just generally looking at it
that there's a general overall general
benefit to physical health and mental
health when you participate more in
religion spiritual and you have faith
but the the types of treatment that
we're talking about now that i i'm
excited about is the fact that people
have compared
for example existing treatment
modalities like cognitive behavioral
therapy
on the one hand
and then cognitive behavioral therapy
plus
religious
uh augmented with spirituality
and compare the two of them they found
that religious cbt
models for depression
or spiritually focused therapy generally
religious psychotherapy for depression
and anxiety
or spiritually augmented
cognitive behavioral therapy have all
been more effective
than the psychotherapy alone by itself
than the cognitive behavioral therapy
alone by itself spiritually augmented
country behavioral therapy
has been very beneficial in decreasing
hopelessness and despair
improving collaboration of care with
patients decreasing relapse rates
enhancing functioning and recovery for
patients
now
they have been found to improve
depression they've been found to improve
anxiety psychological problems
psychosomatic
problems but what is actually really
interesting is that
two things are interesting about this
therapy
the therapist who is non-religions
or non-religious therapists have
actually been found to have
more effective at providing this care
now religious therapist i was really
blown away by that wow i expected that
so yeah there's the most recent one that
came out was it last year or this year
i'm not sure now where um
group psychotherapy
so in group psychotherapy was carried
out in uh hospitals in residential homes
and intensive treatment programs and
that group psychotherapy they added
spirituality to it so it's spiritual
psychotherapy in all these areas
they also found that the therapist who
was not religious had a higher
effectiveness at base than others the
other thing they found was that
everyone improved whether they had
religious affiliation or not they all
improved they had significant benefits
regardless of setting whether the
setting was in a hospital in residential
home or in outpatient intensive
treatment
and also regardless of the patient's
connection or lack thereof
spiritual spiritual beliefs
so this is really exciting i think
yeah it's really amazing to hear i mean
a few things are coming to mind even as
you were talking earlier on about how
that used to be more dismissive it seems
like in some ways that could have left a
missed opportunity a lot of ways for
some of this really effective
outcomes and moving things forward
especially you know even those without a
faith background who seem to be more
effective for whatever reason
in these in these situations as well but
i think it speaks to just the
the power of bringing people's whole
selves and the power of these spiritual
practices as well you know as a
scientist i can imagine that some may
say oh well is that a real effect or is
that just the placebo or is it the
community but i think at the end of the
day the fact that it is having an
effective outcome speaks volumes and
just speaks the importance of making
sure that you don't dismiss that
important part
of people's lives and even as you're
talking it's reminding me of some of the
some of the neuroscience studies that
have been down around this as well
specifically aspects of prayer or
meditation and how people respond to
pain so people who have spiritual
practices who are meditating or praying
to a higher being their brains have a
lesser response to painful situations
and they actually have a lesser or
higher threshold for pain in some of
those situations as well so again tying
in both aspects of general health but
just also how that is actually impacting
our brains as well and i know i'm
leaning back towards my neuroscience
because it's my natural inclination but
it's really
it's really encouraging to just hear all
this research that's coming out and also
to hear that it's being incorporated
that much more so as well
um on that note i also want to ask a
little bit about practitioners as well
because again this is just in my general
impression but i seem to be interacting
with more and more practitioners over
the years who also have a faith
background and i would imagine that
those people and those individuals like
yourselves are also able to potentially
bring that to the table or bring that to
the discussion as well but i'd be
curious how much you're willing to share
about that as well i can also imagine as
you talked about some may feel like oh
is that unethical for me to bring this
aspect of myself into this clinical
situation so how do
practitioners who have faith backgrounds
how do you all navigate that aspect of
things
i think that the question of whether or
not there's been an increase in
practitioners of faith
is a it's a good one uh is is really
whether there has been an increase or
whether people are feeling much more
comfortable
expressing it now than they would have
in the past
um people were worried that people might
see them as all kinds of things if you
present yourself as a particular faith
in this field in this space of
psychiatry so it might be that people
are feeling more emboldened in talking
about it
it also might be that there's an
increase based on
how things have moved i mean i think
our society people are more willing to
express
uh things related to their faith or
their beliefs on this so maybe there has
been an increase as well
one of the things that we always have to
focus on when we are thinking about is
this ethical or is this not ethical and
people have worried about that so
is um
an understanding that if you always put
the needs of your patients first
ahead of anything ahead of your own
needs ahead of your own feelings i had
if you put the needs of your patients
first it's very unlikely for that to be
unethical that's good that's a really
important way to think about it to spend
a second and say
am i doing this because there's
something it is doing for me
it's just benefiting my own self my own
person ego spirits whatever it is
or is this
really benefiting this patient
and if if you can conclude that you are
benefiting your patient
then you should be less worried about
whether it is
ethical or not possible
the fact of the matter is that there are
some religious practices that could be
harmful
and
in those situations you should be able
to to
not participate in that you should be
able to
let the patients know that these
religious practices are harmful to you
and that's not the way to go
even though you respect their views you
respect their religion you
again
this is why it's so important to strike
a good therapeutic alliance
because if a patient believes that you
have their best interest at heart and a
patient believes that you're willing and
open to understanding where they're
coming from to see them as a whole
person
and with everything they come with if
they believe that and they have that
connection with you it actually allows
you to be able to point out when things
are problematic
without them feeling attacked
um because they know that you're coming
from a good place
and so
we can't ignore
bad things happening to patients just
because we want to respect their
religion that would be unethical
we can't
not provide patients with what they need
if the patient needs medications you
can't not
encourage them to take medications
because you're you know you you're in
line with that belief that all they need
is prayer that would be unethical you
know if a patient needs other forms of
psychotherapy to assist them in recovery
you really need to encourage them to do
that as well
as well as encouraging their spiritual
their healthy
non-harmful spiritual beliefs
well said
yeah really well and i love the fact
that it's so
centered on the on the uh the patient
the individual as well making sure that
you're doing all that you can
to support them and to to help bring
that that healing even as you mentioned
about at the beginning that your
motivating factor i'm in all this as
well so that's really important one
thing i should also mention for the
listeners one of the topics we'll
actually cover in an upcoming episode is
having individual psychiatrists who have
actually been involved in specific faith
communities to actually have services
that are offered in those faith
communities as well so both dr ryan and
jordan and dr sydney henkerson will be
joined to talk about some of those some
of those components individuals that dr
dk likely knows as well but again just
really highlighting all these different
components and again kind of
in the same vein of what you talked
about making sure that these practices
are actually put together and it's
really encouraging to hear how it's been
so impactful for a lot of people as well
as we can you know as we get close to
wrapping up i did also just want to ask
a question to talk a little bit about
what gives you hope in the work that you
do
and again even just emphasizing that you
speak and you work and move in so many
different spaces i mean we talked about
your work with patients we also talked
about your work at the state level
you've also testified before congress as
well so
first of all i guess to ask how you
navigate all these different spaces so
effectively and as you do that and as
you engage in the work what gives you
hope going forward
uh i think the question is do i navigate
them effectively
i would say so
you know so yes i am
i think it's again it's been having the
opportunity to participate in
discussions
at all these levels have been
extremely
rewarding
at the american psychiatric association
ethics committee
we
grappled with this idea of the ethics of
practicing
psychiatry and incorporating religion
and spirituality
and i can tell you that it was extremely
heartening to participate in that type
of discussion um
you know so it's not so different from
what i meant by
being present at the table where you
you're part of policies you're part of
decision making and discussions and
part of my role in some of these areas
is to also educate my colleagues who
might have you know no affiliations no
religious affiliations no understanding
to help them understand as well why this
might be important
so
they dual role of
um
policy generation discussion service
provision and care
and education that draw role has been
really really crucial in all everything
i find myself doing every opportunity to
be um
uh to to teach and to educate people
it's a welcome opportunity every
opportunity to participate in saying you
know how can we increase this here or
there or the resources or services have
been really
beneficial what gives me hope
in navigating these areas is
i can say every single time i have
presented this type of topic
i have been impressed with the
number of questions
that i have received from people i've
been impressed with the attempt
attentiveness
of people i've been impressed with the
desire i think the desire and hunger
that people have
to participate in this space and
the people are coming at it from the
point of view of how can i make it work
which is different from oh this is
useless this is not science you know get
it out of here
that's a whole different conversation if
the conversation is you know i'm just
worried i might say something wrong oh
i'm just worried it might come out i
might do unethical things how can i make
it work
i am encouraged by that kind of
discussion i'm very hopeful that people
are paying attention to this
i'm hopeful that even uh um
guiding documents in psychiatry are
putting a spotlight on this area as well
the one area that i think i have really
been disheartened so far but the fight
continues the battle is still on is
training
i think that
um training of practitioners of all
disciplines
social workers
psychology psychiatrist uh therapists of
all disciplines
has been lacking so far in the
incorporation of
spirituality and religion and faith
into treatment
so that is one area that i think we have
a long way to go it has to be something
that we are emphasizing just as much as
we have emphasized bowel psychosocial
yeah it's really important to add
biopsychosocial
spiritual slash religious care
to make it four rather than three
in the in the treatment so that's the
one area that we still need
uh some work we have some work to do but
otherwise i'm really hope i've been
hopeful with how people have engaged
with the topic so far yeah that's
wonderful to hear and encouraging in a
lot of ways to see that movement uh but
to your point also it's it's also
interesting to think about the room the
places where there's still room for
growth as well it actually makes me
think about some of the conversations
that we've had earlier in this podcast
with those in pastoral or clergy roles
as well and it seems like both of those
need to move simultaneously so one
pastor in particular pastor michael
walron who has spearheaded and helped to
develop a hope center in harlem that's
affiliated with his with his
congregation also talked about from the
clergy standpoint how there needs to be
much more in terms of
thinking about aspects of counseling and
mental health care for those who are
going through i think he said for him
there was only one course that he had so
it seems like on both sides this is a
great opportunity for both sides to be
able to integrate that and even
potentially work in partnership but
again at the same time it's it's helpful
to hear that conversation has started
and there are ways that people are
asking questions and wanting to
implement but again something i think is
important for us uh to move forward um
as a society so for any who are
listening who may be leaders in this
space i hope that that's something that
you'll
take to heart as well because i think as
we've heard dr dk mentioned there can be
such a tremendous uh impact that having
those conversations that integration uh
can really have um
the one way to approach those type of
partnerships which i believe are
absolutely crucial
partnership with the faith community
partnership with other advocates is
being respectful
we have to go in
respecting the faith traditions
of the group we have to go in
um helping them understand that we are
coming to enhance what they are already
doing
because they are already doing a lot
we are coming to enhance what they're
already doing we respect what they're
doing
we are not discouraging them we're not
dismantling what they're doing or we're
coming as enhancers and we're respectful
of them that's very important to have
that
or hopefully mutual respect yes yes when
we engage with these partners yeah i 100
agree thanks so much for making that
point as well and again it just speaks
to even as you talked about the
therapeutic alliance it seems like that
needs to happen for practitioners and
faith leaders as well to have again that
level of trust and respect so
very well said and of course thank you
for the ways that you've done that as
well in so many different arenas and
avenues and for your leadership uh and
really leading the charge in a lot of
ways again grateful for your willingness
to be here on this podcast i can't say
enough grateful for the ways that you've
invested in me uh for any who are
watching this is a video podcast you may
get tired of my consistent head nodding
throughout the episode but so many
things that dr dk mentioned definitely
wrestling i think we're so important so
i think again just a really informative
conversation that i think will help a
lot of people even as they think through
some of these components so dr dk thank
you again for being here on the addie
hour and for sharing all these wonderful
insights with us and for sharing aspects
of your journey as well we definitely
appreciate it
and i want to thank you for being in
this space
for creating this space
i think
the importance cannot be over emphasized
it's just
um
allowing individuals to come and present
their full selves
and to be
respected acknowledged
by someone who is so accomplished as
yourself
i think this is wonderful i
i'm just proud of what you're doing and
i'm proud of who you're who you've
become and who you are still
growing to become i'm very proud of it
so
i keep keep the flag flying and i wish
you all the best
thank you very much that means a lot
especially coming from you and i'll
definitely continue to uh to move
forward with the undergraduate and the
mentorship and investment that you and
so many others
have given me but that's i'm very
grateful very grateful to hear that
thank you
[Music]
you